kimber is in Pittsburgh hey Kimber
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hi Dave
thanks for taking my call
sure what's up I just wanted to get your
advice on my situation my husband and I
are 27 years old
and last year I quit a full-time job to
pursue my wedding photography business
and right now he's kind of looking at
our goals for paying off my student loan
and saving a lot more kind of mostly in
preparation for starting a family next
year perhaps I'm considering a full-time
going back to a full-time job but also
hopefully maintaining my photography
business but I sell pursuing full-time
that will impact my business so just
wanted to get your thoughts on what you
think how much debt do you guys have not
counting your home I have ten thousand
eight hundred and fifty five dollars on
my student loan that's it your whole
house not counting your house that's
pretty much it
my husband has loans that we are not
paying those right now okay I'm asking
how much debt this couple has not
counting your mortgage you have ten
thousand a $10 of student loans and he
has how much in student loans I don't
know because his parents offered to pay
that when when did they when are they
gonna pay it I honestly don't know how
long have you been married we've been
married three and a half years it's time
you know this is affecting your life if
they don't pay it okay okay it's very
important it's in his name they're going
to come take his income
if it's not paid so the details need to
be something you and your husband both
understand and agree and even with his
parents agree that what's scheduled this
is going to be done okay if it's gonna
take 40 years that's not okay this is
gonna take four months that's okay you
see so I mean if he has two hundred
thousand dollars in student loan debt
and his name and they want to take 40
years and pay it off well that's sweet
but that's stupid okay I know it's not
that much you see what you're saying you
need to get the whole thing okay now and
what does your husband make a year about
32,000 okay and how much have you made
in wedding photography in the last 12
months this year about fifteen thousand
what did you make it your full-time job
before about twenty-two thousand okay
you already made fifteen doing weddings
right yeah no you don't need to go back
to work you need to beef up your wedding
business and or take pictures of things
other than just Brides right I don't
care if you take pictures of sports
teams or puppies but long as they're
paying you I want you to beef up your
photography business whatever it is by
seven or eight thousand dollars which is
more than you would have made then going
back to work so no let's let's get your
let's get your business geared up what
can we do to get the marketing up and
acquire more customers and let's get
excited about that that it has more
opportunity than you going back to work
and it's something you can control your
timeline on if you decide to have
children and so forth in the near future
like you said right that was the idea in
the long run but I wasn't sure if I was
I wouldn't you far out yeah I just I
just get desperate for customers it
wouldn't be a long run thing it'd be
like by the end of summer how can I make
$5,000 shooting stuff with my camera cuz
I'm good at it and people pay me money
for it I don't care what it is you can
make an amazing amount of money shooting
sports teams you can people will pay for
doggy portraits now I mean it's what I
don't care
whatever it is it interests you in
addition to Bridal shots but you
probably shots are booked way in advance
and weddings are and so you don't have
the same you know you've got too much
lead time you can't just make good money
by auguste doing that so you need
something it's got a little quicker
turnaround time and it's like you know
we do vacation shots for families for
their while they're at the beach for
their for their Christmas card or
whatever I don't care whatever you know
more about it than I do but let's get
your I'm gonna send you a copy of
Christie Wright's book the business
boutique
it's about ladies running their own
businesses and she's got great things to
say in there and I think you've got
about 15,000 more dollars of untapped
potential or more I think you can be
making more than your husband and just
own your own business by the end of the
year and then let's get dialed in on
those student loans and figure out what
they are and start to get them all paid
off by both of you doing that instead of
saying gosh my business didn't
organically naturally grow by osmosis
I'm gonna go take a job no let's get
after it hustle and grind you can do
this
hey you got a lot of potentials don't
don't don't walk past it